speaking of being unserious um here's
another another example not just in the
government but also in media so the view
you know if you tune into the view
whoever makes the mistake of doing that
um maybe
i don't know i don't know what you're
expecting when it comes to something
like this i don't know if you're
expecting
in real insight into uh into geopolitics
from the ladies of the view but if
that's what you're looking for you're
gonna be disappointed um here is joy
behar what's what's her main you know
concern what is she worry might happen
if this um if this conflict spreads and
becomes a world war yeah there's global
warming but as far as she's concerned
there's um
a consequence even more dire than that
listen
estimates are 50 000 ukrainians will be
dead or wounded yeah and that this is
going to start a humanitarian crisis a
refugee crisis in europe we're talking
about five million people
that that are going to be displaced i
mean
it's it's heartbreaking to hear what is
going to happen yeah well i'm scared of
what's going to happen in in western
europe too yeah you know you just you
plan a trip you want to go there i want
to go to italy for four years i haven't
been able to make it because of
of uh the pandemic and now this you know
it's like who's gonna what's gonna
happen there
and now this
first there was a pandemic of five
million people died and it stopped me
from taking it my my italy vacation that
i've wanted to take it's been my
dream and now we have war
what else what else is going to happen
to me is joy behar so i think some some
very compelling arguments have been
presented to putin
and hopefully he's paying attention
because
listen you got to stop this
because if you don't
it's going to kill more polar bears from
global warming
and if that's not enough to persuade you
mr president
then also you're preventing joy behar
from going on an italian vacation that
by the way she's wanted to take for four
years
we'll have to see
i'll have to see if that if that does
the trick well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content